to live hey everybody what's going on
play here well gonna stream Coco got a
sweet pugs shirt on today looking good
feeling good
Beth Morosky here in the chat room don't
spook I told you never to speak hey gang
how is everyone today
do you know Bailey's back Jason rallies
back creeper the corner
let's get that let's get that thumbs up
and that's got a thumbs up belongs
I like putting this right over Beth's
face as soon as the counter head comes
out tonight
very excited ah my new clueless gamer
fallout 4 very exciting very excited we
got dressed up in in suits saw the
things on Facebook there we got dressed
up in suits it looks pretty great skin
tight suits by the way we're back skin -
are we back
can people hear us that's right that's
right Slayer Darth that's right shady ah
shady loves the Pug shirt we're gonna
play some uncharted 2 today but before
we did that I just wanted to show you a
quick photo of us in the means it's
crates that was a mess what a mess
skin tight suits guys crazy it's awesome
I mean a super fun time we played a lot
of I got to play fallout I've been
playing Fallout 4 for the past couple
months basically and I'm very very
excited because that game is
unbelievably fun and cool and so watch
tonight that's great it's it's gonna be
a really fun game ER and we did some
special things that I think you guys
will like to see there we go
there's a nice shot look at that look at
that there's a nice shot the suit
they're all these leather things I might
start wearing leather more just some
leather things could be great um yes NIC
Phil says is there any kind of suit
other than skin tight not good not any
kind of matters we're gonna play
uncharted 2 today because we've been
making our way through the Uncharted
games because though we hear those are
fantastic and I want to get a taste of
those before the fourth and last one
comes out so let's start it up it's
gonna be great
Thank You Minton Co appreciate it I got
this for two dollars at a whoa
Oh oh my god whoa Oh maybe he was just
eating pasta you know what I'm saying if
he just paused it
Chewbacca's dad you should wear the red
leather jacket I got you worried were at
war in raw one day one day one day Oh
believe me Smith says because uncharted
2 is the best well we'll see oh my god
oh that's bad so I guess we'll answer
I'll answer some questions a slayer
dresses so Aaron what cooks our projects
were involved with before joining team
Coco if you don't mind me asking well
I've worked for Conan since oh one
before that I was involved in project
called college and came well yeah I
worked at Kmart I worked at Kmart in the
sporty good section actually I got a
great idea I have a great I have a great
this is great
start out mother right
great idea like crazy Kmart stories when
I worked at Kmart one of them is I would
instantly forget my read Kmart vest and
so they would just let me borrow another
one but then I wear that one home so
literally my house my parents house in
Michigan I have let's say like Darth
blurts and all these like ridiculous is
crazy hashtag bleh stories exactly hey
Gingrich could deceive playing bacon
what's up joy joy what's a Monday May
least we have that technical
difficulties I agree captain Queens okay
I get you a job here as a custodian
I cannot our custodians name is Sam he's
the man and he's very good at his job
actually I puked on a tree at 5:00 in
the morning on Saturday night outside of
a stranger's house does that count as
I threw up like right on a tree like I
was like Handa the thing just vomit on a
tree it's not good then I went back
inside I was like I need to go home and
then I went home and then I slept that's
my life it's horrifying
all right now I think we're good I think
we're gonna play all right so we can
stop the band Hammers dropping the
stream died uh Gingras might have broke
the stream oh my god O'Malley's rushing
back and forth it's the stream dead
papers on it frozen screen whoa look at
this can everyone see the fact the guys
hanging from this train shame shame
frozen scream not let it go the stream
is over now we did it
hey Sigma 88 Kmart's I've another great
Kmart story you wanna hear a crazy crazy
carrot story doesn't want him to talk
yes it's possible yeah the Kmart lobby
is shutting me down this actually might
not be an appropriate story for the
street all right that's good all right
it's good now we're gonna play thank God
you guys got safe right Tara what cam
right story all right rock and a hard
place you know here's the thing a lot of
people say oh it's like you know in a
hard place but some rocks are soft like
a limestone is a pretty soft rock you
know you don't think it's a soft you
don't think that's soft well it's not
like an obsidian an obsidian is very
hard you're not gonna want to
metamorphic rock you know metamorphic
rock is one that's chained it's like a
isn't a metamorphic rock guys help me
out
it's strength oh man there's a
metamorphic rock like something that's
like lava what's a lot what's the minute
what's that like a lava rock this guy's
got great drink is amazing I'm right
Thank You creeper thank you over
Lootera not what's hashtag stream dream
like that laughed be a slimmy Bhim loves
Limi BIM let's leave even I love your
name and we got to go up more right am i
going up what are we doing
metamorphic that's right ignatius pieces
of tofu that's obsidian Ignatius
Ignatius is like a volcanic all right
yes whatever it is whatever Oh miss I
need a refresher on geology's now I
corrected my pronunciation but yes
exactly
hey there's a there's there's Ignatius
there's metamorphic then what's another
one chill like like max chill there's a
max chill rock look max chill rocks are
like granite it's like super max chip
it's good professor
oh god what do we think about Russia get
advances in the new Olympic Games Oh
hey that's a good idea
Beth endorsed is it not sure lay indoors
what would happen in a Blake on your
fanfic I would get beat up quite a bit
slim e-beam I like pugs although a
sedimentary now sedimentary rocks is
like the what that's like that's like
limestone right that's like sentiment no
no I think it's like rocks that are like
created when a bunch of sediment gets
compressed right or am I making that up
that's good man drink is great like
finger strength I'm saying Nick Nick
Phil if I know one thing about Nathan
Drake it's this everything usually works
out for him and it never gets worse just
like Beth yeah exactly everything works
out for Beth all the time nothing works
out for me ever ever I puked on a tree
that's what happened to me whatever it's
probably cuz you ate too much yeah you
probably ate too much soup or something
you drank too much English breakfast tea
you drank too much wine your own house
you puked on a wall wild wall it was
right there is not an acceptable answer
for why did you throw up on something
what am I going here Nathan drinking
Beth sitting in a tree that was people
yep guys listen the tree had it coming
alright I went right for you it's okay
we still love you concur says where am I
going
we need to have the Conan head travel
the back of the couch Oh what do you
mean Eeyore Oh God you puked on a tree
what's wrong with you I'm sorry where am
I going here what am I supposed to be
doing
three kind of get up what am I supposed
to do what am I supposed to go here
he's just I'm leaving this guy hanging
thank you yeah where am I supposed to go
anybody know where I should go
please somebody Nathan Drake needs your
help I've been pressing up in X it's not
working just let go slay me Ben trust me
extra yellow guys me yeah I can't
yellow guides you bro I'm trying to get
on the train Nick Ville I'm moving on to
ghouls for my late-night streams what do
you mean ghouls I'm moving on to I'm
gonna be playing fallout 4 on Wednesday
on my own there we go
I'm the old twitch.tv slash Erin Blair
come on by it's a real depressing and
dark Oh God
oh no let's go drink get up there Drake
Drake damnit Drake you suck at jumping
says the guy who couldn't do this in
real life jump on the net there's no
next you deserve to die Drake where's
the button that makes that kills this
guy oh yeah listen to you or don't talk
to me like I don't know about Fallout oh
right I put two hundred hours into
Fallout 3 and then I got robbed and they
stole my hard drive I was really upset
okay I was actually just wish they'd
stolen like my identity more than my
hard drive for fun
Oh No Kappa quasar I don't know where
the hotline bling' x' happens but no
girls ever call me so it's not worry
about it right now his fingers got to be
really cold there we go
speaking of which today I've been
wearing more sweatshirts and stuff cuz
it's getting a little chilly here in LA
today I'm I'm I'm kind of I feel a
little self-conscious about my fashion
choices today I wore a hoodie that has
no sleeves it's dark blue and black
right I feel kind of like it's very 90's
boy band and so I kind of was like I had
to go in and talk to Conan this morning
about our fallout 4 gamer and I go in
and the first thing I said was look
before you say anything I know much my
sweatshirt doesn't even sleeves I bought
it like this and whatever and he comes
out and he he he stepped he stands upon
his - you guys don't worry about it and
he's wearing almost the exact same thing
except it's like instead of a hoodie I
said of a hoodie with no sleeves he's
wearing a dark blue vest the black
hoodie underneath so we look like twins
and he's like don't worry about it I was
like so just a case I should have taken
a picture of us
that's right kind of hard to imagine a
it doesn't get cold here because it's oh
no Ron Ron Drake oh Jesus
whoa this game is awesome no jeez uh mr.
Rogers yes we're playing Fallout 4
tonight tonight clueless gamer oh I
think you guys are gonna be very happy
we go out of fun gun I really like the
game it's a beautiful game it's great
I'm gonna put a lot of hours in my life
into that game this guy looks like what
a douche sure he's wearing worse also ly
42 I think ly sent me a bunch of
affliction t-shirts thank you by the way
but they're all extra-large and I wear a
medium so I can't wear that they're too
big for me they're too big but have you
send me affliction by the way I don't
what time is it right now all right it's
1218 I called 28 minutes ago I called
our interns and asked them to bring over
a case of Diet Coke so I could drink it
cuz I need some caffeine clearly because
I'm very low-energy 28 minutes ago
intern has not showed up here is that
shut up we might need to get on the
phone we might need to get out of the
phone and get them over here cuz I
guarantee you they just took it down to
the office in exactly to eat to wear
them places LK bTW I can't I need to
show these muscles off my fliction
t-shirt maybe I can get them tailored
although getting an affliction teacher
tailors it's like but I'm just saying oh
wow if you want to send me mediums I'll
wear them
I'll do it if anybody wants to send me
any clothes I will wear it on this
stream this is already what I'm wearing
I can't look any Dumber and I switched
from a a sleeveless food exactly let's
see show that intern who's boss is
pancake lover sounds like for every 10
minutes the inter needs to wear a tude
it needs to lose a tooth
that's right
happy Peterson when does the close gamer
drop on YouTube good question that's a
question for the old Beth Morosky there
we go these are Pacific times yes kappa
deez nutz I will wear Victoria's Secret
if you send it I will wear it on the
street
it might be underneath oh that's true
that's shoe yeah that's a good point
that's a good point I am very much
looking forward to servers battlefront I
played I love Anna Kendrick and if
you're watching which I know you are
please come on the swing I played it at
e3 I had a blast I didn't I didn't have
time to play the beta of it Aaron I'll
be watching you Aaron I'll be watching
your so expect me what's a Fantasy Bra
is that like a Lord of the Rings it's
like a bra that's like Lord of the Rings
a fantasy bra okay bTW I constantly ask
Jordan to come on the stream and he
constantly refuses to come but maybe you
know what maybe we'll try to get him on
playing battlefront Kappa Deez Nuts
I did not go to Blizzcon we were far
away in another land in a desert land
Princess Leia bra exactly oh it's
covered in gemstones the Fantasy Bra
sounds like something Nathan Drake would
wouldn't ride upon exactly yeah I think
I think all this exposition well that
she's got a hair in her face that's
annoying I think I'm just gonna guess
but I think that they're gonna they're
getting together to try to find some
kind of artifact don't you think I think
that's probably what it is some kind of
artifact it's literally been a half hour
it's we're coming up on a half hour for
how long it's taken the intern to get us
some diet coke
I think we should call again I think we
should I think we should call them again
I'm gonna call them right now there we
go
they definitely brought it
they definitely brought it to the office
I'm gonna call them again right now all
right here we go
should I put him on speakerphone let's
put him on speaker
putting on speakerphone hey hey drew
what's up hey it's Blair can can you do
me a favor and you break some diet do
you know where the digital studio is oh
wait wait forget it I gotta go
here she is come on in no no come take a
seat take a seat
take a seat all right introduce
introduce yourself to everybody in the
chat hi hey Meredith
thanks for diet coke hi Meredith do you
want one of these right now all right
open there I'm gonna crack open my own
cuz I don't I don't want to get your
germs here do you want a diet coke oh
man I cook we're not a diet coke we will
accept money from you if you want to
give us money now when I called earlier
did you answer the phone no we are
waiting on groceries waiting on
groceries this is the last these are the
last time coach oh my God thank you so
much right so you're saying is these are
valuable outs and no one else has any
Diet Coke in the opposite surprise
Meredith might be the next Mindy Kaling
says Vicki stalls that's right exactly
when you speak of the coke devil the
coke devil appears exactly now is this
your first time in the digital studio oh
you were already on camera no it was
that was just you were just testing it
out for this that's right well what do
you know you're on the string you've got
you've now graduated from rehearsal of
the show pretty great all right get out
all right thanks Meredith Meredith
everybody she did it she found the
digital studio bra static oh we're all
very happy that's right oh my god
Tara not says playing a Jewish series of
ceaser ish mini concert videos yes I
went to the fallout 4 launch party it
was a lot of fun
I literally bumped into Jerry
Bruckheimer letter like physically we
made contact I've been really into
boomerang lately I'm really getting into
boomerang so boomerang is like this
little app it's like a little bit goes
back and forth it's very fun and I
boomeranged a lot Calvin Harris played
walk the moon
was great block party was fantastic
but yeah we had a lot of really fun
times there at that thing yes
Chewbacca's dad hahaha enough screentime
for unpaid intern oh man I will say now
it's a little bit warmer with all this
fire yeah you know I think it's melting
slowly I mean it's pretty cold probably
I got a gun you need a gun
Evan Peters blade to use the power of
our interns to feel good about yourself
since color always messes with me
no I don't I will say though I hate me
final treasure I do feel I like to have
fun with the interns because I was an
intern and no one kind of had fun with
me so you know what I'm saying like I
actually like to you know talk to them
like the real people which I know is
shocking and groundbreaking but but yeah
because they're people just like us it's
always locked yeah but have a gun bro
ain't no lock staying in my way gun
fight coming CBR says pure Scorpio
fallout 4 graphics are bananas bananas
just it's gonna be incredible Hey
whoa well that worked out really well we
don't know that that guy could have been
a good guy Karma's a we don't that
kind of could have been you know he
could have had a couple of good kids you
could have done a lot of charity work
for him to get blown up like that is
kind of presumptuous I think what's
going on here
yeah I did yes
before you start I did I did tell her to
get away but you know it's kind of in a
joke jokey way right yeah we're stuck
murders and I are still pals yeah
exactly
interns are just like us until there's a
natural disaster and then they are
floatation devices Wow that's dark not
wrong but dark yeah and and I mean
unless you're talking about they're like
bloated corpse or something humans don't
really float naturally did you ever see
the end of Titanic spoiler alert Jack
sinks to the bottom and dies oops I
haven't seen the new Star Wars trailer
nor will i they already have my money I
don't need to keep spoiling the movie
for myself but I'm very much into it
whoa nice jump there Drake e Drake
ooh Alaric's chromes his favorite scene
this is your favorite scene sorry shady
whoa whoa oh no I'm not back on a train
it's gonna fall
oh Jesus whoa oh ouch ouch ouch man this
guy is good lord
Star Wars is overrated said zu 93 ah
wrong it's extremely rated it's rated
properly when is my star finally
eclipsed Conan's that hack has had its
day hopefully never because then I'll be
unemployed ooh sexy lady cool accent
these games
Flynn's got like an Australian accent
she's guy it's kind of English but it's
like a little something else in there
big jump Buster bear girls there's
nothing on this guy my pal one of my
best friend's works for Bear Grylls
that's blue back arrow you play a game
of super smashes me I sure will don't
look look no you can't fourteen yeah oh
my god that he's touching her but no but
I told you bad don't look at this scene
Flint's play by Steve Valentine who's
Steve Valentine Gingras this girl's
Trouble Man
never trust a big button to smile that's
what BB D said and that's the word
that's the world I live in
BB D Bell Biv DeVoe yeah that girl is
boop boop it up put it dip it up in it
you know that song that girl is poison
poison poison you've never you guys know
Bell Biv DeVoe right 14 you're only 14
all right he's back up here we go
get up Drake
lovely woman on the MacBook
I don't know Slayer Darth but the woman
on the MacBook is Beth murasky snap she
is me
poison yeah poison see crazy half 31s
feeling me poison put put never trust a
big but this man that girl is yeah
exactly
Conan's getting a weird teeth spider
says he's like huh oh there's a video
game sex scene that plays playing
exactly Oh guys just wait til fall off
for clueless gamer tonight so excited
thank you guys are gonna like it and I'm
dead and I'm dead I'm dead so you never
trust a big button to smile what
happened I trusted a big butt and a
smile and I died
I don't know where I'm going here
shots fired yellow pipe
I haven't played zo sunny 3 I haven't
played a lot of the Metal Gear Solid
games I just jump across where oh oh I
see I see
oops yeah yeah
jump to the L pipe jump man you have to
jump jump jump alright guys I get it
here we go jumping boom
sorry I just all caught up in the tree
I'm still trying to think if I should
trust big butts and smiles or not yeah
it's very distracting I mean like look
that was the nineties you were younger
back then we didn't know about big butts
or smiles but now we know and we're
cautious so maybe we should start
trusting Beth what's your position on
this big butt in a smile situation I
think Beth Peppa depe depe de bit a bit
but if it if I were you I'd take Prakash
you've never heard that song can you
pull it up we could probably play music
on here right ah ah I think you should
put either you should pull it up under a
computer we need to play a little bit of
poison I don't know if it's allowed or
not can we play that fairies alright I'm
gonna comment commentary on this pull up
poison we need here right guys we need
to hear this put it near the mic no no
we can keep the sound on oh yeah oh yeah
you need to mute the twitch room
I need to tell everyone I do
Chewbacca's dad Beth probably was
listening to call me bad calling me bad
by the way my first concert opening up
for Paula Abdul
well it's everybody's first concert
sound off in the chat I want to see it I
don't know if anyone has a more
embarrassing first concert than me it
was like cold-hearted snake days
you can play music but it'll be muted on
your VOD says shady there we go here we
go oh that's it
can you hear this
situation is move Cannibal Corpse
Concrete Blonde oh yeah great song
slurred ours has never been to a concert
or musical plays get out there try this
is a gate that's good oh my god
oblivious miss might win all right
that's enough of that song we can't hear
it anyway oblivious message was American
Idol season 2 tour that was an
embarrassing concert the obliviousness
might take the record Travis open up for
Oasis the lead singer Travis with Swami
perform which is great plays the classic
oh yeah joy joy says bled lake us link
us to the song that's gonna link you to
the song you got pinkie stalls in sync
that's a pretty good one Fall Out Boy
was your first concert yeah oh my god
you're so young bus today UK band back
in 2003 with shady fringes pink open up
for in sync that's pretty close beau
Casper's orcs or kasturi's his little
fellas Sigma says we have a slight echo
coming from the gaming Ricky Martin
captain quasar nice whoa keV the coroner
says Bob Dylan when you were 15 wow
that's pretty good I stopped cause I'm
in a Bob Dylan that was pretty good
million to Paul Simon which was awesome
pieces of tofu's asking hey cool Tom one
two three four five good to see
thank you for joining us Slayer Darth
the only proper concert I've been to was
for smokey and her smoking Oh war zone
Wow death night
where's that great Rolling Stones Rush
Sigma yeah really stones is great Jojo
ever been to a concert you got to get
out CBR first concert journey Queen
that's awesome I love it we uh we got to
interview Fall Out Boy with Harry
Shearer on this couch actually right
here we haven't even fought Pete Wentz
at right right over there and who's that
here there's a lead singer who's here
Patrick something I don't know oh the
guitar player I thinks that were you're
playing alright let's climb up on some
ledges look a man like a cool Nathan
Drake is he doesn't even need to hold a
flashlight it just keeps it like dick
level he's just like look at this like
if you look this way it's just like look
it's like a shiny look at this he's like
he looks like he's got like a look at
this he's got like a light boner Los
Angeles everybody know about this there
was a UFO on did it look like a giant
boner
the programmers were fine with this
hashtag light boner
hashtag electric boner that's a good
band name if you need a band name go
with electric boner electric boner I'm
not gonna move this guy I see somebody
used the hashtag electric boner cuz I
need that out in the world yeah yeah
he's flashing the camera light boner
this is pretty sexy man maybe I should
make this like my tinder profile pic
electric boner ah
fleshlight Keplinger said nice work the
true light saver exactly there we go
George I got the first electric boner
hashtag alright you know what helps is
holding your thing not at boner level
all right shut up idiot
everyone's got an accent I'm night
alright baby babe nope he's not actually
it's not like the good old days at all
my boner is lighting up the wall whoo
eclectic boner well done
read by nature he Schwartz is as big as
mine oh yes baseball is classic how can
you tell it's all pipes and water and
crap probably you know it's kind of
freaky I saw this video on the guy in
the parrot zone in Paris and the cat
there's catacombs underneath the city
right yeah miles of catacombs and they
made a movie about it called as above so
below and it's okay the end is kind of
fun but this guy it's based on this guy
who got lost the Paris catacombs they
found a camera with this footage of this
guy running around and we're walking
around the Paris catacombs this is on
YouTube by the way and you hear him and
he starts he sees something and starts
getting really nervous and starts
running it's like it starts like
freaking out and drops the camera and
then they found it he was never found
his body was never found but it's super
super creepy this is a real to thing and
that's why they made the movie is kind
of based on it but it looked just like
this thanks dude look it up on YouTube
YouTube it dude bro do you even YouTube
Paris catacombs horrifying you loved as
above so below shady fridge do not doubt
this game it makes it way better ziz the
official philip weiss
why are you why are you whispering
there's no reason to whisper there's no
one around no guts no glory that's not
true at all
you can have glory when no guts go in
here what the catacombs they don't like
the video it's like an ood it's free
it's really scary don't watch it late at
night or watch it late at night it's all
yeah it's super Blair Witch II how is
Beth 14 it is never used that's a great
great great question Nick though are we
going here why am i trapped yeah it's a
creepy video by the way and real by the
way so there you go it's it yeah it's
like Sleepless in Seattle to Whitney and
the catacombs beneath Paris Oh Tom meet
me in the catacombs beneath Paris with
all the demons we should cosplay first
oh that's a good idea
I'll cosplays Beth I'm gonna guys laughs
I'll wear this you always wear and then
like something striped and then the same
jeans I wear some t-shirt with comedy
words on it that's right once again if
anyone wants to send us any clothes or
anything we'll wear them on the stream
we will I'll make it better do it or
I'll bring in an intern to make them do
it what are we going here you know my
electric boner is not really showing the
way I have heard of no man's sky filled
whites I've played it actually with Sean
Murray the Creator very nice guy it was
pretty cool actually I went to this at
e3 I went to this like private apartment
like talk to her like 45 minutes and got
the got a private viewing in the game
which is really fun and yeah that looks
like a real fun game also it's a little
mind-blowing but very fun where should
people send clues
is if you like google it I don't want to
like say it on the air but I think if
you google it you can find where our
office is hard it's on the it's on our
website all right we just got a bunch of
dresses and now I've just talked myself
into a corner of wearing a dress which
is comfortable by the way have more
dresses before I'll wear them again like
a boner why don't you find it huh oh we
both got electric oh man double electric
boner look at this that's great that's a
screencap virus semen should we touch
our electric boners I kind of went maybe
I'll Mick what happens if two electric
boners touch don't cross the streams
that's how stars are made there we go
all right here we go up here just keep
going up ha ha ha across the streams
turn on
[Music]
Evon or ash alright let's go hop down
hop down pal
hop down hop down hop down let's go
let's go they're like captain I don't
know what that means
Beth you should know you're 14
I think that's an olden times thing it's
from the ninety thousand even born man
this guy's athletic where's your babe
hey Jett Haig's is here was that last
two weeks ago Paige is two weeks yeah I
do like the Dinos oh you're dead it's a
nice ringtone what are you oh you're
dead stupid yeah we go jump up gotta go
this way
now where do I go
here we go helps that everything here is
yeah press circle to drop to a lower
ledge what YouTube asked about a few
like the new James Bond the name the new
James Bond is not good someone was
saying I liked it it's good it's like
fine he's not amazing
how's Christoph Waltz he I loved him
sort of like I love him but he's the
same he's not being dick yeah I loved
there are some fun moments and in
Skyfall and Casino Royale was amazing
the Armenia episode is next Tuesday yes
the 17th
Raptor nom if I play any other games I
Naughty Dog what are some other Nadia
games
what's my friend codes you can add me
it's just my name twitch.tv slash Erin
Blair hey bad wolf what's up the best is
yet to come people keep saying the best
is yet to come in this game when does
the best actually come that was a bad
choice of words
hashtag electric boner
I love the official film white says I
bought all this stuff get on my level
then says it'll be here next week
bro get on our level we're streaming we
got this stuff already
what am i doing I'm not paying attention
to anything here oh oh mmm no electric
bone or anybody this looks like my
grandparents attic this game is all
about attics we'd have to go somewhere
Oh
Bolivia's missed the last of us was
amazing one of my favorite games of all
time why don't you follow the conduit
why don't you do one thing
Flynn where's the conduit at you have to
find the junction box to disable the
alarm got it got it got it
we just have my boner light the way
[Music]
dude I just jumped like 30 feet and I
can't get on a box are you kidding me
up this junction box nope
oh that's the junction box though this
looks Junction II
why I wonder if Lin's gonna betray me
probably hates such a beautiful eye
what's up oh man you got to go to a
biology lecture snoresville um oh wait a
second
tell us tell us something tell something
you learned in biology such beautiful I
pressed forward and tap all right all
right got it oh look at this guy
easy can I kiss him now these passed out
can I kiss him on the lips I just want
to wait can I kiss him though I want to
kiss him okay yeah just like huh let's
make a great gram he's standing on your
chest
ooh crash bandicoot 2 Crash Bandicoot
was Naughty Dog awesome big job buster
as a biologist I feel offended somebody
tell me something cool about biology
prove to me biology score yeah so far
geology is winning the science race here
on the couch we got it ignatius rocks
what do they call again igneous rocks
we got metamorphic rocks we got
sedentary rocks we got pop rocks the
most important kind of rock yeah so what
do you got biology they're learning okay
we are learning about the replication of
DNA what how does DNA replicate somebody
explain it to me that DNA is like this
thing right in charades whenever DNA
comes up this is what I do and people
get it at once people just immediately
go like oh yeah RNA is kind of harder
DNA is good
do I like breathing that's biology mmm
is it or is it more physics cuz think
about it to breathe your diaphragm goes
out it sucks the air in right that's not
biology that's physics snap hugs not
drugs kids staff drugs and stay off bugs
cuz yeah you know I kill bugs stay off
drugs and keep off bugs cuz plugs you
can't ride a pug all right what button
learning about corner transitions while
you're learning about my ology
oh there we go
tacos are biology that is that true I
don't know I know when you eat a taco
that's biology right like date night
gaming I'm new here lots of questions
wait date night gaming is that Mac no I
wonder if teen night gaming is Mac ICU
Mac if that truly is you conan says hi
hey there Mac whatever it's Mac
I can't wait for fall uncharted for
that's why we're playing this game
you're a boner mythic us as you're a
boner makes the spiral staircase which
is why the light cones okay I believe
you
his wife oh it's Mac's wife hey max wife
good to see you good to see you I'll
explain later
I love it yeah I didn't know if Mac
could be able to watch because we're
talking about a boner electric boners
might be off limits I didn't kill him I
just knocked him out I gave him a
concussion he's got something on his
mind mainly the rock I put him into you
up cream shooters here through proteins
and enzymes one splits it easily in case
one indicates a certain play reputation
one okay yeah it's nice to see such a
beautiful lie that you're paying
attention to biology I did not pay yeah
I didn't pay attention to biology or
really anything which is why I'm
basically unemployable here we go
how was Flint already up there oh no
damn he's sleeping but you will kill
some later all right fair enough
smash his head into a rock that's
biology for you that's also me trying to
learn about geology more than more than
a year I think
[Music]
so dude do i just attack these guys what
do we think Oh
oh yeah then let's let's stop let's stop
around on him a little bit
I just like talking a man hey mr.
diamond want a tea good to see you
I'm waiting for you dude
always have a seat of new peanuts movie
nor will I I want to cowl it in Hobbs
movie man I mean no offense against
peanuts but bring me some Calvin and
Hobbes that's the best i'll go right you
go left alright I'm going left
understand left where where am I
supposed to go you're going right I'm
going left I'm going this way
walk up the stairs pal if you know it's
good for you nope nope don't come this
way don't come this way don't come this
way don't come this way
the last Calvin and Hobbes coming broke
my heart oh the last count of Hobbes
comic no it didn't it was good I mean it
breaks your heart because the last
Calvin and Hobbes and story sad but it's
awesome it kind of ends like on a really
great note
oh god oh there we go
cartoon style eh or definitely cartoon
style you don't want them real you want
a real life Calvin Hobbes movie because
that's like yeah yeah yeah you wanna I
think you want to experience those
things in the same way that you did in
the comedy you wanted to be all 2d it'd
be tough though I think to get the voice
right for Calvin who who played good
Calvin and who play good Hobbs
I feel like Seth Rogen might be a good
Hobbes know or like kind of or like a do
you want like a John Goodman type if
they make it like the Garfield movie I'd
rather they leave Calvin and Hobbes
you're right you're right
Nick Phil uh last man on earth I'm
watching just phenomenal I watched all
of mr. robot I can't recommend it highly
enough
those two shows are my two phase just
saw the new Mission Impossible which was
do Tom Cruise man love that guy no
problems with him I always root for him
well I'm supposed to go laughs Tim
swisco this way no I'm going the right
way
well fine there I've never played the
wolf among a Slayer Darth do I need to
play that game for Nathan curry yeah ah
I wish I had my electric boner because I
can't figure out where to go here his
best movies Rain Man I don't know man
Christmas had some good movies he's
great the Mission Impossible flicks am I
going down here what am i doing oh yeah
I gotta kill that guy right you know
Aaron Scientologist confirms yeah no
thanks damn I just kicked that dude in
the back of the brain hashtag three all
right
Oh oh yeah that was great
all right here we go
it was such a beautiful I said I'm a
Mission Impossible baby born about five
days after my mom watched the first mi
in theaters sexy now where do we go up
here I guess stay out of the light right
that's the game
wait didn't I just beat this guy up I'm
literally back to where I was the gate
you say I went up to the gate there's
one more guy to knock out right Oh
downstairs okay
some over here treasure wait somebody
said something about suffocation being
induced biology sinus tree
I think biology is interesting I just
don't have the smarts to do it the best
way to kill a person is to wrap dry ice
and newspaper and put it under the
victims bed you'll suffocate in his
sleep in the morning when the
pathologist arrives the dry ice will
have subliminally and none of the
pathology tests will be able to
determine that the suffocation excuse
whoa all right fair enough you can also
just yeah I you know here's here's the
way I like to murder people here's my
here's a murder tip you take them out to
a nice dinner okay
and you have a really good time then you
uh the next week do it again maybe you
take them to a movie okay and then over
the course slowly of months couple
months you date them all right and you
then you get serious okay then you and
then you move in together then you get
married then you have a couple kids you
get a house you get a dog you move
across the country to another place you
both get jobs that are you know mildly
satisfying and then you start doing
little things that you know annoy them
okay like you don't put the dishes away
or you know maybe you disagree in front
your children and that's up and then you
and then that happens over like 40 or 50
years okay and then you slowly drive
them crazy but like in a lovable way and
then you die of old age first at like 80
or 90 and then they feel really bad for
a couple years before they die I mean
it's a long game it's a long time you
know but that's that's how I like to to
murder people that's my preferred method
what about you guys let's take a dark
turn
that's murder I don't know I don't
really want to give it away oh happy
well I think we just learned that Beth
he's either gonna murder me or O'Malley
she's gonna murder one of us too and I
think it's probably me it's true I
deserve it definitely not part of the
diet coke
it's the DC talking the game of life
exactly exactly
Oh John Marcie GI
I love the Fall Out Boy I think I don't
already go here by the way I just want
to kill one more guy speaking of murder
how do i what do we do here
or Jordan's gonna murder Conan Dobby
murder at this office Oh
Labatt's is merch if stabbing them in
neck fair enough what is this uncharted
guys life is pretty uncharted you know
the game of life I can't reach up there
can't jump across down here I think I'm
on the right way though does this feel
like the right way
math you're totally gonna bribe the
interns to poison air and supply of diet
Oh totally damn it
I got me that's what it is sell me out
what do you think I love it
how do you make left left and down some
of the same Oh Todd Levin is asking
about croissants what do you want to
know croissants from scratch Christel
croissants I mean we can look it up I'll
come up to your office after this and we
can go over it Todd and I are working on
the next clueless gamer it's very
exciting left you say Oh left up
here we go this is the way this is the
way right
is this the way this is the way one drop
at a time says bad wolf you talking
about
lever it was to your left oh you too bad
bleh if you I was a let the cutter is
crazy
a lot of fun up gameplay stopped no no
you know what I think I think that's a
sign I think maybe we should stop for
today what do we think guys thank you so
much this is super fun
oh we're gonna finish on the technical
difficulty camera today all right thank
you for joining us this is a blast
please please watch clueless gamer
tonight fallout 4 it's very exciting
it's me and this guy where's the thing
there it is it's gonna be a blast it's
very epic I think you're gonna love it
and if you miss it tonight which you
shouldn't but you can check it out and
we'll be blasting in everywhere of
course as soon as it airs so thanks a
lot thank you all for joining us and
we'll see you next Monday ice cream
cocoa focus on drugs
you